[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch this
video that's been heavily requested
Marvel Avengers sacrifice I believe it's
a tribute video from the channel the
Garowe studios I'm looking forward to
checking this video out before we do
that since this video is Marvel related
I feel like now would be the perfect
time to tell you guys about Marvel
puzzle quests which is available on
Android iOS and PC that's right with the
new year upon us and so much Marvel to
look forward to the good people at d3 go
thank you guys for sponsoring this video
by the way are bringing you even more
MCU goodness with their latest update to
Marvel puzzle quest Marvel comics
fearless superheros come together in
marvel's official and only match-three
puzzle RPG mobile gaming experience and
guess what it's free to download you
know and when I download things
personally I like them to be free there
are over 175 of your favorite heroes and
villains packed into this game so you
create your own epic dream teams choose
from Iron Man Black Panther Deadpool
Emma Frost venom recently added
characters like Domino Bishop and
Prowler there are a hundred 75
characters in this game so we're not
gonna name them all right now but the
best matchups you can think of either
way get ready to unleash your dream team
in various puzzle events and tournaments
once you've got your squad in place you
can join your friends or other Marvel
fans across the world that's part of an
Ultimate Alliance and compete against
others across leaderboards and weekly
tournaments which offer rewards to both
you and your Alliance Marvel Puzzle
Quest also features fun and engaging
storylines to play through written by
actual Marvel comic book writers battle
your way through intense plots and
participate in various Marvel inspired
events and if you download the app using
our special link you'll get a free three
star Spider Man I didn't know that yeah
sooo good of an offer I think we should
take it away
it's not what they want us to do that
that's right homies light up your screen
with some match-three fun by hitting
that link in the description box and
downloading Marvel puzzle quest today
thank you guys so much for sponsoring
this video you guys are awesome and here
let's look at the sacrifices the heroes
have made
[Music]
destroyer see where your power
I know what it's like to lose so
desperately
that's right
[Music]
I asked you to what end ready
this is really well cut
Zulu's just this much more excited for
endgame
should have made the sacrifice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sacrifice really is like somebody
especially [ __ ] infinity
[Music]
[Music]
Oh may all arms choices are part of the
strongest
don't we don't get to choose our time
[Music]
but those Jeff Bridges person a couple
haha everybody get hurt
I lost my life surrounded by my enemies
damn twice he's had to lose the room
in times of crisis one single
[Music]
like epically
I can't do the left which is a proper
yeah - don't invite thinness to your
jazz night or your spoken word poetry
day or anything like that because he's
gonna be grooving and just decimating
people left and right it's gonna be the
next fight scene not a confirmed theory
well we've seen several of you know
these like Marvel super cuts this has
got to be one of the best emotional ones
you really do go on quite a journey
because it's like yeah obviously this
video is called sacrifice there's a lot
of themes of sacrificing having to do
the sacrifices for the greater good
gotta give up to go up laws of
leadership people also going into a
place of understanding you know the
importance of death and giving like
there's that line they quote from the
ancient one death is what gives life
meaning to know your days are numbered
your time is short you know kind of like
they're there Marvel contracts actually
I'm not gonna be playing these
characters and making them big fat
paycheck forever going from that
sacrifice and then also I love how when
they transition with Black Panthers line
I think it's at the end where they're
pulling the line from the end of Black
Panther in times of a crisis
one another as if we were one single I
know they have this like giant board you
know how they work they map this out but
fanatically speaking is something I
don't really think about you know think
I might think about Easter eggs or
theories predictions of whatever but
fanatically speaking it seems like it's
always just sort of been there I don't
know if is just because this is cut
super well and they've taken this right
line and this right image because I
appreciate in these videos especially
when they could take a moment or two
that doesn't feel as somber or poetic
but then throw it in here and then make
it feel that way well yeah they'll bring
out you know what might have been
percolating underneath the small moment
in context of one movie when put in this
montage you know plays up what was
probably really at stake you know what
that scene was probably hinting at or
whatever and I like that a lot about
this I mean I kind of agree this is one
of the most potent Supercuts like this
I've seen because I think this video is
really good at kind of taking like
images and motifs and kind of playing
them out in a linear you know spacious
fashion where it's just affecting you
know more than anything I mean it's a
lot about yeah sacrifice obviously but
it's different bonds between these
different characters who have had to
fight together even little things like
the knife and the significance of the
knife that gives her they choose a
number of moments where that comes back
that's what I like also like sacrifice
and death bringing people together and
what the struggle is for because a lot
of it is intentional sacrifices in other
areas it was just a sacrifice that
happened it was just a death that
occurred weirdly Oh another thing that I
thought was more amplified for me from
watching this one you know how people
talk about with infinity war but like
it's really fantastic movie Thanos is
the protagonist of that film a lot of
people view it in that fashion and I
felt like he was even more amplified
because of exploring the themes of
Thanos throughout this video all these
heroes are constantly making sacrifices
for the greater good and then you take
moments of infinity war where Thanos is
straight up talking about whose choices
strongest wounds having to make
sacrifices and going Wow Santos really
is this unique darker mirror to who the
heroes are what makes him just the
ultimate villain I feel that even more
so now because of this video
oh yeah well because he's got a version
of the greater good on his mind - yeah
which is a hard debate to go up against
at least you know in a story come on the
next point when you have two sets of
characters who just believe the opposite
thing so hard yeah
and that's also just what's scary about
life and stuff but and I like that they
started out this video with the whole
Infinity stones thing the sort of
kickoff point it's funny because I
constantly forget benicio that's in the
MCU yeah and I completely forgot what
his voice like his accent choice for
this so I was like whoa and then you go
back you're like he's the one who really
laid out what the Infinity stones are
for us so he actually has one of the
most important roles in the MCU the
information he's laid out for us that's
the completely important character I
don't know why I never hit me you know I
love guardians 1 it's one of my top five
favorite MCU films and you know I loved
infinity war just hit me watching this
like oh wow Rockets had to lose groot
twice i've never pieced that together
just how much of a harrowing effect that
must be on rocket himself you know oh
this really brought me into a mindset a
space of viewing that that's real heroes
yeah it's people it just cuts to the
themes you know underneath you know the
true struggle and it's like inspiring in
that way because what this is basically
showcasing is yeah just a bunch of
people who care about what's good and
right ostensibly and who are willing to
fight as hard as they can and use the
means they've been given in pursuit of
that even from the villainy side of
things and it is potent yeah way like
those it is very stirring emotionally
well I think it's easy to get caught up
in the excitement you know the best
people sometimes call it the Marvel
humor the fun not realize that what
makes these connective tissues so strong
it what makes this franchise so strong
all these films so like so many years
later so strong is they always have the
themes the poetic undertones throughout
from the very beginning you know I never
that together would Toni talking about
how if you die you know that'll be on my
hand yeah he says and then he dies in
his hand and you're like wow is this is
even the more you dissect the MCU the
more you code the thought process and
how meticulously planned out it is like
some of this might be just by chance I
don't know if they have a board up there
where they little like you're the themes
over the MCU either way it's cool that
it's constantly presented because you're
cutting around all the characters and
they all touch on it in some fashion
you know this the sacrifices of being
here yeah of any kind at all and it's
also a testament to the MCU that all
this cuts together so well because these
are mostly sequences from Avengers films
but there are a couple pulled in that
are from the other MCU stuff and and
they all do just feel like one giant
universe thing yeah and it's also cool
that a lot of times in my big spectacle
movies death is something you kind of
become immune to in some ways or
violence here you you do see that the
the emotional toll that all this
violence they have to put up with or
endure or participate and does take a
toll on them which adds to the whole
cure department like I said it's easy to
get lost in all the other surface stuff
of fun and everything which I love the
reason people can put together such
great super cuts of the MCU is because
they have these deeper things that are
really running throughout so yeah I love
this this is I thought this was a very
beautifully done via video let's hope
you see super cuts where you're like I
mean they really have to try to hide
that music in that one scene or you know
yeah and I never felt that it looked
like they got the raw clips oh alright
guys well what is the reason you love
the MCU as much as you do or Marvel in
general put it down below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification bell and more
importantly make sure to hit that link
in the description box and download
Marvel puzzle quest today thank you guys
again so much for sponsoring this video